[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Sirin schönen guten Abend
zusammen katja hat später den
sportlichen Teil der Sendung hallo und
guten Abend dann blicken wir jetzt
gemeinsam auf unsere Themen
dicke Luft vor flüchtlingsgipfel Bund
und Länder streiten ums Geld und die
Ampel um den richtigen Kurs in der
Asylpolitik
Angst und Misstrauen in der Türkei die
Opposition befürchtet Wahlfälschung mit
den Stimmen toter Erdbeben Opfer
und ein beschwingter Charles nach
opulentem krönungskonzert folgt ein Tag
ehrenamtlicher Arbeit
[Musik]
vor dem bund-ländergipfel übermorgen
wird weiter über den richtigen Umgang
mit geflüchteten gestritten die
Ministerpräsidenten fordern mehr Geld
die ampelregierung weist das zurück und
sagt wir geben schon genug sie will
stattdessen auf konsequentere
Abschiebungen setzen und auf
asylvorprüfungen bereits an den
EU-Außengrenzen über schlechte Stimmung
vor dem flüchtlingsgipfel berichtet Lars
bodensack die Flüchtlingsunterkünfte der
Hansestadt Lüneburg sind überfüllt die
Kosten für Unterbringung und Versorgung
kann die Kommune kaum stemmen die grüne
Oberbürgermeisterin rechnet vor was bei
ihr von den bundeszuschüssen ankommt von
den letzten 1,5 Milliarden Euro die im
Bund ausgekehrt wurden sind in der
Hansestadt rund 585 000 € angekommen das
reicht für die Deckung der
Betriebskosten bei der Unterbringung von
geflüchteten Menschen genau für einen
Monat allein bis Anfang Mai haben fast
90.000 Menschen einen Asylantrag in
Deutschland gestellt bis Jahresende
Bündnis 300.000 sein Länder und Kommunen
verlangen mehr Geld sie fordern dass der
Bund nicht mehr pauschal abrechnet
sondern wie früher Geld je nach
flüchtlingsaufkommen gibt ich strebe an
dass wir zurückkehren zu einer
pro-kopf-berechnung insoweit kann man
natürlich jetzt keine starre Zahlen
nennen aber ich gehe mal davon aus dass
wir fast von einer Verdopplung
derzeitigen Zahlen sprechen müssen in
der Finanzminister jedoch verweist auf
die jetzt schon hohen Zahlungen des
Bundes
der Bund leistet ja Milliardenbeträge
zur Unterstützung der Länder und der
Gemeinden jetzt steht aber anderes im
Zentrum wir brauchen eine andere
Flüchtlingspolitik wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass es weniger irreguläre
Migration nach Deutschland gibt und dass
die Menschen die kein Aufenthaltsrecht
hier haben unser Land auch wieder
verlassen tatsächlich plant das
Kanzleramt eine massive Verschärfung der
Flüchtlingspolitik so soll es mehr
Abschiebungen geben Personen die illegal
eingereist sind könnten künftig in
abschieberhaft genommen werden und es
sollen zentrale ankunftseinrichtungen
entstehen aus denen direkt abgeschoben
werden kann hier legen sich die Grünen
quer das ist ein Revival eine Horst
seehofischen Innenpolitik also wo auf
ähm wo zwar Rechtsstaatlichkeit
eingeschränkt wird aber am Ende kein
einziges Problem gelöst wird das wird es
nicht geben viel Diskussionsbedarf für
den flüchtlingsgipfel am Mittwoch und
bis jetzt ist keinerlei Kompromisslinie
zu erkennen
wir gehen nach Berlin Patricia
Wiedemeier ist dafür uns Patricia
konsequentere Abschiebungen das ist
schon ein neues Stil in der
Kommunikation der Bundesregierung was
steckt dahinter
naja zumindest für die SPD und dann auch
gedeckt von der FDP es ist eine Antwort
auf die Situation die sich ja derzeit
wieder verschärft die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge nimmt deutlich zu in den
ersten vier Monaten dieses Jahres wurden
in Deutschland laut Bundesamt für
Migration und Flüchtlinge gut 100.000
Erstanträge gestellt also sieben nein
78% mehr als im Vorjahreszeitraum der
gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt wird
zunehmend schwieriger das Klima giftiger
es gibt wieder Anschläge auf
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte und die AFD liegt
in den Umfragen weiterlegt in den
Umfragen weiter zu die Regierung sieht
sich jetzt unter Druck daher fordert die
SPD Abschiebungen konsequenter
durchzuführen doch die Erfahrung zeigt
so richtig klappt es bisher nicht mit
der Abschiebung aus den
unterschiedlichsten Gründen
Innenminister von Phaser setzt darum
auch darauf über Asylanträge gleich an
den EU-Außengrenzen zu entscheiden und
dann die Flüchtlinge gerechter in Europa
zu verteilen auch das jedoch schwer
durchsetzbar und in der Ampel streiten
sie mal wieder die FDP fordert auch die
Maghreb-Staaten zu sicheren
Herkunftsstaaten zu erklären um mehr
Flüchtlinge abschieben zu können die
Grünen lehnen das ab die Ampel
untereinander Bund und Länder
gegeneinander die Differenzen sind groß
ist dürften nicht nur am Mittwoch beim
migrationsgipfel schwierige Gespräche
werden vielen Dank Patricia
Niedersachsen spricht sich dafür aus die
heizungspläne der Bundesregierung um
drei Jahre zu verschieben zahlreiche
Fragen seien noch unbeantwortet so
Wirtschaftsminister ließ in der neuen
Osnabrücker Zeitung als abwegig
kritisierte er zudem die geplante
Ausnahmeregelung für Menschen ab 80 laut
neuem Gebäude Energiegesetz sollen alle
neu eingebauten Heizung ab 2024
klimafreundlich sein
Deutschland muss mehr Tempo machen beim
Klimaschutz wenn es bis 2045
klimaneutral sein will so der
umweltprüfbericht der Organisation für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung OECD im Verkehrssektor sei
der CO2-Ausstoß weiter viel zu hoch
durch umweltschädliche Subventionen wie
Pendlerpauschale und Dienstwagenprivileg
stattdessen müssten das Schienennetz und
der öffentliche Nahverkehr schneller
ausgebaut werden
am 8 mai 1945 kapitulierte Nazi
Deutschland an das Weltkriegsende vor 78
Jahren wurde heute bei
Gedenkveranstaltungen und Kundgebungen
erinnert an der neuen Wache in Berlin
gedachte der Regierende Bürgermeister
Wegner gemeinsam mit dem ukrainischen
Botschafter makayev der Opfer von Krieg
und Gewaltherrschaft ein Großaufgebot
der Polizei sicherte die Veranstaltung
ab es blieb überall friedlich
in Weimar haben sich mehrere hundert
Demonstranten versammelt um gegen einen
Auftritt von Björn höcke am heutigen
Gedenktag zu protestieren der Thüringer
AFD Landeschef will in diesen Minuten
eine Rede halten
das Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges hat
auch in Russland große symbolische
Bedeutung Moskau würde bei seinen
traditionellen Feiern zu gern auch
Erfolge in der Ukraine präsentieren und
habe deshalb seine Angriffe verstärkt
meldet Kiew allein in der Nacht habe es
16 Raketen Angriffe gegeben vor allem
auf die Städte kakiff der Song Nicolai
und die Region Odessa auch Kiew wurde
wieder beschossen und auch an der Front
in bachmut verschärft Russland seine
Attacken Volker Duck berichtet
in bachmut geht es heute um alles wie
jeden Tag die Bilder der ukrainischen
Luftaufklärung zeigen deutlich die
russischen Angreifer wollen die Stadt
unbedingt einnehmen noch vor dem 9 mai
dem Tag des Sieges gegen Nazi
Deutschland und der wird in Russland
Morgen gefeiert
dafür setzen sie nach Angaben der
Ukraine auch verbotene Phosphor und
brandmunition in bachmut ein ein weißer
tödlicher Regen der alles verbrennt nach
zdf-recherchen ist die Stadt da unten
bachmut die internetaufnahmen sind nicht
älter als drei Tage auch diesmal
kommentiert Moskau die Vorwürfe nicht
in Kiew meldet die Luftabwehr den
Abschuss von 35 russischen Kamikaze
Drohnen eine stürzt in ein Hochhaus
zerstört mehrere Wohnung 5 verletzte
man wird das alles ändern das Schlimmste
ist dass wir bereits gelernt haben damit
zu leben wir sind morgens aufgestanden
haben das Kind zur Schule gebracht es
ist beängstigend
in Odessa an der Schwarzmeerküste wird
bei einem Raketenangriff auch das
Lagerhaus des ukrainischen Roten Kreuzes
getroffen auf einer Fläche von tausend
Quadratmetern wird alles zerstört
mehrere Projekte müssen erst einmal
gestoppt werden
Luftangriffe und militärische Paraden
ein Kalkül das offenbaren Kriegszeiten
aufgeht in St Petersburg proben sie
schon seit Tagen für die
Gedenkveranstaltung morgen in 21 anderen
Städten wurden die Paraden erstmals
abgesagt oft ohne Begründung oft wegen
sicherheitsbedingten
Ukraine ist Präsident will auch hier den
Bruch mit Russland silensky legte heute
ein Gesetzentwurf vor das Ende des
Zweiten Weltkrieges soll künftig einen
Tag eher gefeiert werden gemeinsam mit
den Verbündeten im Westen
neben offensichtlichen Angriffen auf dem
Schlachtfeld orchestriert Russland ja
schon lange auch weltweite Attacken im
Internet aber auch Infrastruktur auf dem
Meer über und unter Wasser ist offenbar
im visiertes Krems es geht um
Internetverbindungen wichtige Pipelines
oder bedeutende Verkehrswege und helfen
eine noch unveröffentlichte Studie zeigt
wie schutzlos sie möglichen Attacken
ausgesetzt werden Pablo silai
vergangenen September Gas strömt nach
einer Explosion aus der nord-stream
Pipeline in die Ostsee schnell wird klar
es war wohl Sabotage auch wenn ich
zweifelsfrei geklärt werden konnte ob
Russland dahinter steckt die Angst im
Westen wächst das Moskau die Unterwasser
Infrastruktur Europas angreift die NATO
geht nach einem Bericht der britischen
times jetzt sogar davon aus dass Moskau
bereits explosive Materialien an
neuralgischen Orten platziert haben
könnte eine Koordinierungsstelle zum
Schutz der unterwasserinfrastruktur
wurde eingerichtet Chef ist Ex
Bundeswehr general Hans Werner Biermann
er sagt der Anschlag auf die Nord Stream
Pipelines im September vergangenen
Jahres hat deutlich gemacht dass die
Gefahr real und von strategischer
Bedeutung ist auch die Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik arbeitet an
einer Studie zu Bedrohung der
Unterwasser Infrastruktur durch Russland
mit Autor Göran sagt die NATO
Erkenntnisse decken sich weitgehend mit
seinen Recherchen
in den letzten Vorbereitung getroffen
hat um die Verwundbarkeiten der
kritischen Infrastrukturen auch für sich
zu nutzen besonders im Fokus moskau ist
das Gebiet um Großbritannien hier
verlaufen mehrere wichtige Verbindungen
zwischen Europa und den USA eine Art
Datenautobahn zwischen den Kontinenten
westlich von Großbritannien und westlich
auch Irlands haben wir einige sehr
wichtige Datenkabel über den Atlantik
laufen in den letzten Jahren haben wir
sehr viele russische Aktivitäten in
diesem Bereich gesehen
LNG Terminals und Offshore Windparks
haben Schwachstellen Europas unter
Wasser Infrastruktur so viel steht fest
ist verletzlich
die Befürchtung der NATO zur kritischen
Unterwasser Infrastruktur dazu gleich
ein ZDF heute live mit Fregattenkapitän
Göran Swiss Deck von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik um 19:30 Uhr in
der ZDF heute App und auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen jetzt ein Termin auf den
auch in Deutschland oder Europa viele
mit großem Interesse schauen die Wahlen
in der Türkei am kommenden Sonntag die
1,5 Millionen Wahlberechtigten in
Deutschland die dürfen schon seit Tagen
abstimmen zwei Anwärter gibt es den
zunehmend autoritär regierenden
dauerpräsidenten Erdogan
und den Kandidaten der Opposition
Klitsch da dorolo gerade weil sich ein
enges Rennen abzeichnet befürchten nicht
wenige Wahlbetrug möglicherweise sogar
im Zusammenhang mit dem schweren
Erdbeben und seinen zehntausenden Toten
Anna Feist berichtet
adiamanen schwer zerstörten Südosten der
Türkei zu Besuch in dieser von der
Oppositionspartei CHP zur Parteizentrale
umfunktionierten Teestube das größte
Problem sind die die tot sind Ihre Daten
stehen noch im Wahlregister
rechnet mit mindestens 40.000 Erdbeben
Toten allein in adiaman offizielle
Zahlen sprechen aber nur von mehr als
6000 Toten vielen Opfern wurden bereits
Stimmzettel zugeteilt die könnten nun
missbraucht werden
wir wollen mehr darüber erfahren
Verabredung mit zweidorfer Stern aus der
Region sie zeigen uns die Wahllisten
tatsächlich stehen hier mehrere Personen
die beim Erdbeben gestorben sind die
Dorfvorsteher werden die Namen von der
Liste löschen lassen am Wahltag
aufpassen dass kein Missbrauch
stattfindet hier sei das möglich
in meinem Wahlbezirk gibt es 330 Wähler
ich kenne jeden von ihnen aber ein
adiaman zum Beispiel gibt es Viertel mit
10.000 Wählern dort kann nicht jeder
jeden kennen
wir fragen nach bei dem Mutter dem
Statthalter eines Bezirks in adiaman der
zur AKP gehört der Mann ist zuständig
für mehr als 6000 Menschen seit 15
Jahren bin ich Bezirksvorsteher ich weiß
wer tot ist und wer nicht sie kennen
wirklich alle Menschen hier also alle
nicht aber hier weiß man einfach ob es
diese Person gibt oder nicht
der Vorsitzende der CHP will sich darauf
nicht verlassen
schon in der Vergangenheit kam es zu
schwerem Wahlbetrug dieses Mal wollen
wir das verhindern
sie haben deshalb hunderttausende
freiwillige im ganzen Land angeheuert
die aufpassen wollen dass am Sonntag
keine Stimmen von Toten mitgezählt
werden
ein schwerer Fall von Rassismus sorgt
heute für Empörung eine Schulklasse aus
Berlin musste ihr Ferienlager in
Brandenburg abbrechen weil sie in der
Anlage beleidigt worden sind und bedroht
mehrere Schülerinnen trugen Kopftücher
eine andere Gruppe aus der Region störte
sich offenbar daran erst vielen
rassistische Bemerkungen später hätten
sich einige der anderen Gäste vermummt
und auch körperlich gedroht heißt es
Polizisten muss nach eigenen Angaben
eine Eskalation verhindern jetzt wird
wegen Volksverhetzung ermittelt
Charles der dritte und Königin Camilla
die können es auch locker beim großen
krönungskonzert gestern Abend war das
deutlich zu sehen vor der malerischen
Kulisse von Schloss Windsor ließen sie
alle Anspannung und strenge Zeremonie
hinter sich und tanzten ausgelassen so
Musik von Lionel Richie Katy Perry und
take Bett der Bericht von Hilke Petersen
um das zu feiern kam 20.000 nach Winzer
und die royale Familie tanzte
heute als alle frei hatten arbeiten die
Royals und das ehrenamtlich so der
Wunsch des Königs für Prinz Louis die
erste offizielle Verpflichtung
renovieren bei den Pfadfindern
der britische Premierminister sunack und
seine Frau machten sich in der Küche
eines Seniorenheims nützlich mehr als
1.500 gemeinnützige Organisationen
hatten aufgerufen etwa im Londoner Green
Park Blumenzwiebeln setzen
was gegen den Klimawandel besser als von
Netflix zu sitzen stattdessen was Gutes
tun
vor großer winzerkulisse nicht nur zur
Ehren des Königs sondern für alle die
dem Königreich etwas geben Auftritt
eines laienchors Britten aus allen
Schichten
aber auch Größen des Showgeschäfts Tanz
Opa und Popp
[Musik]
Lionel Richie brachte die königliche
Familie ins Schwingen
[Musik]
dann auf der Bühne der Thronfolge er
würdigt das Engagement des Königs für
Umwelt und Gemeinwohl und die Queen auch
irgendwie anwesend
über uns von dort oben und wäre eine
sehr stolze Mutter Papa wir sind alle so
stolz auf dich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
US Superstar Katy Perry im metallischen
Outfit voll und König in Feierlaune
[Musik]
ja und so tatsächlich also in Fireline
und Laune auch der BVB gestern nicht
ganz so wie die Royals offensichtlich
aber ziemlich meisterschaftsverdächtig
war das was Borussia Dortmund gestern in
der Fußball-Bundesliga abgeliefert hat
6:0 wurde der VfL Wolfsburg aus dem
Stadion gefegt und Einnahme war in aller
Munde Karim adejemi
dortmund feiert Pflicht erfüllt der BVB
sitzt den Bayern im Nacken die
Meisterschaft spannend Karimi mit einer
seiner besten saison-leistungen 1:0 14
minute dann treffen alle und malen und
hat die Jenny schnürt nach dem Wechsel
den Doppelpack auch für einen kleinen
stimmungsdämpfer ist adiemi
verantwortlich erzielt vom Punkt zu
ungenau Bellingham dann kurz vor dem
Ende mit dem Sex zu null der BVB wieder
in der Spur wir werden viele gute Dinge
aus diesem Spiel rausnehmen wir werden
aber auch ein paar Dinge rausnehmen die
wir deutlich besser machen wollen nur
noch drei Spiele dann will die
Mannschaft den Fenster die Schale
präsentieren
alles zum 31 Spieltag finden Sie bei uns
natürlich auch unter heute.de und in der
heute App
Argentiniens superklassico hat
Geschichte geschrieben allerdings eine
zweifelhafte River Plate gegen Boca
Juniors das ist immer ein umkämpftes
Derby dieses Mal gab es aber insgesamt
sieben rote Karten alle in der
Nachspielzeit grund war eine
Elfmeter-Entscheidung die im Anschluss
zu Tumulten führte River Plate gewann 1
zu 0
nicht nur die rodelwelt trauert um
sepplands er war 30 Jahre Bundestrainer
und unter seiner Führung gewannen Rodler
und Rodlerinnen 96 Medaillen bei
Olympischen Spielen Welt und
Europameisterschaften sehr blenz wurde
88 Jahre alt und noch dies Tennisprofi
Jan Lennart war ganz nah dran am größten
Triumph seiner Karriere im Finale des
ATP-Masters in Madrid und da lag er dem
Weltranglisten zweiten Carlos algras
dann aber doch knapp
nach einem magischen Lauf und einer
Woche wie im Rausch verlässt Jana
Strumpf Madrid zufrieden der Spanier al
Caras zieht sein kraftvolles Spiel auf
entscheidet den ersten Satz für sich mit
sechs vier doch Stoff bringt den
spanischen Titel Verteidiger phasenweise
an den Rand der Verzweiflung gewinnt
sogar den zweiten Satz 6:3 im letzten
Satz setzt sich dann wieder der Favorit
durch sechs zu drei für alas trotzdem
zählt Strom nach dieser Woche zu den
Gewinnern klettert von Rang 65 der
Weltrangliste auf Rang 28
und kann schon bald Alex ferref
überholen unter Umständen vielen Dank
Katja zum Schluss noch ein in vielen
Partnerschaften heikles Thema
babyvornamen auf manche trendbewusste
die Nachwuchs erwarten kommt vielleicht
eine echte Herausforderung zu etwa wenn
sich auf dem Spielplatz beim Ruf nach
Noah oder Emilia diverse Kinderköpfe
rumdrehen die beiden Vornamen sind im
dritten Jahr in Folge die beliebtesten
in Deutschland ähnlich die Lage bei den
folgeplätzen auch alle Sophias Emmas
Matthäus und Leons haben beste Chancen
das Klassenzimmer später mit
Namensvettern zu teilen
so das hätten wir geklärt das Wetter
noch nicht ganz das ist morgen auch
geteilt sonnig im Osten eher verregnet
im Westen Details gleich von Katja
hornefall
Niedersachsens Ministerpräsident weil im
heute journal Interview ab 21:45 Uhr mit
Christian Sievers schönen Dank fürs
Interesse und für Sie noch einen
entspannten Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend strahlende Sonnenschein gab
es heute im Norden und auch im Nordosten
Deutschlands vom Westen kam dichte
Wolken heran die wurden so ein bisschen
abgebremst und es gab Schauer und
Gewitter besonders hier im Westen zum
Beispiel auch in Nordrhein-Westfalen
auch jetzt in der Nacht gibt es noch
Schauer und Gewitter die letzten
Gewitter ziehen allerdings Richtung
Nordsee raus und auch am Alpenrand
kannst mal reinschauer geben im Osten
ist es dagegen klar und da wird es dann
auch kalt da sinken die Temperaturen auf
sechs bis drei Grad unter dem dichteren
Wolken im Westen bleibt es bei 14 bis 10
Grad deutlich milder und morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 16 Grad
in der Eifel und 23 Grad rund um Erfurt
und auch morgen ist das Wetter komplett
zweigeteilt zwischen der Donau und der
Ostsee scheint die Sonne strahlend krass
anders sieht es im Westen aus da ist es
bedeckt da fällt häufig Regen es sind
auch einzelne Gewitter dabei bei einem
Wind aus südöstlichen Richtung am
Mittwoch erreichen die Regenfälle dann
auch den Osten der Donnerstag wird auch
wechselhaft am Freitag aber kommt dann
im Nordosten schon wieder die Sonne zum
Vorschein an den Temperaturen ändert
sich in den nächsten drei Tagen wenig
sie liegen zwischen 12 und 22 Grad guten
Abend